foreign at least is the Wild and Hawks
it's set to do battle here tonight
we mentioned off the top this is preseason game
number four for Minnesota just number two for
Chicago these teams will see each other again
Thursday night in the windy city we're underway
in St Paul Alex kalagowski back to pick it up
for Minnesota around to Nick Catan he sends it
out to Center Ice Addison hits the Chicago line
and feeds duer Dewar throws one on goal in a pad
saved by solder Bloom sometimes you want to take
a bite of that forbidden fruit and start playing
a different style of game but they get right to
their game on the four second cycle wow that's
a tag up here and now we get our first look at
the combination of fat military and Walker and
whistle back in for Chicago and he scores beats
Gustafson with the first shot by the Blackhawks
and the visitors are on the
board first it's one ZIP
quick and twisted just coming up the
wall he's got it on the inside of the
ice right hand shot coming down the left
side just a little snap and cost of sin
it's a tough look right over the glove glove a
little low from Gus to sit on that shot from the
wall up over the top of it and find the right
situation now those two along with Damon hunt
they make up that Prospect Laden Decor in Iowa
Augustus comes out here for an aggressive save
back off goes right for it and Gus is in on
the other side spoke appropriately you know
understanding what the wild needs from the power
play what they're looking for he gets the job
out front and a good look is denied by solder blue
that's how they're going to generate their offense
good little battle to aim nice little feed over
the door and he gets a lot on this one but she'll
be able to see that game on Valley torch North
actually both of the two remaining games the
tan in the corner tried to Center and it would
deflect it up off the shoulder of solder blue
O'Rourke plays it back in here from the circle
had his shot knocked away Lambos into the corner
spins it back up high for patan patan fights
off a check from it with salorca shot he scores
they have been tipped out front to
him was supporting with a screen
but O'Rourke finds the back of the
net for Minnesota and we're even 1-1
wins this Face-Off and boy that line
executes like their top line out there
Face-Off play into more possession
patan dancing back and forth before
last man winning the battle saws over
to O'Rourke and then he throws it on net
it looks like it might catch a piece of the
Sweeney in for Minnesota his shot to flex to
the corner doc got it there for Chicago held by
Addison Boulder to eat got it through him to the
slot in the back Canter by Sweeney knocked Away
by solid blue with a shot gloves save solder blue
final two minutes of the first period Beckman
steps up intercepts but then fires high and wide
around behind the net LA Terry has it looking
for Walker out front but it deflects across ice
O'Rourke there his shot deflects wide backhand
champion [Applause] [Music] Walker had the first
chance it deflected away to Beckman finds the
back of the next Minnesota has the lead [Music]
good back pressure from backman who
held his puck in the zone forced to
turn over and then Chicago caught on
their heels and Sammy Walker jumps on
a loose Puck wins the battle oh it's
backhand on Chicago defense forehand
Sammy Walker shouldn't win that battle
but he takes her Kinski first round pick
hey look they're a big part of uh you know us
turning things around here they're they're a
big part of the team they're a big part of our
identity and uh you know we we as a group all
felt that uh we're better with them um so it was
worth the investment in these people can you run
us through the process quick here you know the
guys are a year out extension talks start I mean
who who initiates is it the agent calls you call
them off for a deal like how does it go you mean
who blinks first yeah it does come together fast
I don't feel like there's a lot of blanking going
no there's not they just really liked his his
messaging especially on the power play and then
uh you know personality wise he just seemed
to be a good fit with the group uh hey look
talent wise size-wise commitment all that stuff
he's he's very good he's very mature for his age
now that one goes in
four on some period malagosky in for Minnesota and
they've scored maybe kicked in
and it's immediately waved off
but gogoski is a nice job freezing the defense
finding a little lane hitting that far pass
does kick the toll to skate up I think he's
just trying to gain possession of it but
for the glove side don't Nashville down the boards
Gutman with it Gutman gained some space his shot
knocked Away by Gustafson golegowski can't
find it Gutman hammers another one off the post
a bad goal lead to two three four five against
and he's able to stop the bleeding did that
tonight as well first one got past him and
he stopped 17 cents and then John marrow
who's what he brings that golegoski does and
is simply wait a lot of the same things just
a little more size potato splits the defense in
for a shot and a save by solder Bloom yeah again
Shifty little move skill player jumping right in
between nobody's coming because chip it right over
the glove and I think as I mentioned earlier
there's a team that had 15 picks in the top
three rounds over the last two years they have
nine in the top three in the next two seasons so
it will be a very young pour and that core might
be two three years away from killing an NHL roster
as gusterson slides across to make another big
stop on radish 75 seconds to goal doc moves into
the Minnesota Zone cut off by Addison back to the
line could you set it across raderson they score
doc got to the loose Puck behind Kalin Addison
knocks it into the empty net and Chicago ties it
the Terry loses his d-man a little bit slips
to the middle he gets caught too close to the
wall and opens the lane to the middle then
Beckman tries to cover for his teammate that
opens up that right shot from the flank
and the wild just gets spread out
outnumbered at the net before Augusta City
we've seen golegowski with a little overtime
Magic scored the winner of the night he was
honored for playing in a thousand NHL
games last year what a moment that was
like a turning point this season too
[Applause] is against Carolina right
never forget his post game Quest interview
with Kevin Gord where he said stick with us
carries in for Minnesota [Applause]
and the Wild winning in overtime [Applause]
[Music] foreign [Applause] [Music]
[Music]